[Music]
not many pupils get to learn from a
robot teacher now doesn't knock off at
five o'clock he's never stressed out and
he doesn't ask for a raise he's a
humanoid robot with an interesting goal
now wants to become a teacher today he's
teaching geography and these are his
first pupils they communicate with now
using a camera and microphone today
they're learning about sustainable
development explaining fats is easy for
the robot but what makes a good teacher
his empathy and understanding how is a
machine supposed to respond to
children's feelings how can it motivate
them ovid coppice is a psychologist
who's pursued research into emotions
from more than 25 years his work
combines the fields of psychology
neurobiology and computer science he's
teaching robots to be empathetic
the bunnies on a machine and party by
Clint so nice so how can we teach a
machine empathy return and technical
support blame them on the one hand it's
a tactical problem that needs to be
solved so i'm finin gotta skate on the
other hand we first have to establish
what it means to be empathetic cloud
sustain vez highest empathy in the gifts
console and there are lots of different
opinions about that forget to stop in
the simplest form though it's about
recognizing what the person I'm
interacting with is thinking and feeling
it's mine computer the scientists first
step is to analyze how teachers and
pupils interact with each other the
basics of what we call emotional
intelligence to be able to act naturally
now has to recognize his environment and
identify the emotional state of his
pupils at the moment the robot still
needs help with this a psychologist is
in the control room and gives now brief
instructions and helps the budding
teacher when he gets stuck initial
results show that robots can be helpful
in the learning environment children
respond to criticism from a robot better
than from human teachers but for a
conversation children still prefer a
real person
at the moment teachers don't have to
fear for their livelihoods robots do
best when they're the teacher's
assistant for example by helping
children who have learning difficulties
the mechanical mentor does have one big
advantage he could teach in any number
of languages but now still has an awful
lot to learn then maybe one day he'll be
given his own class to teach